[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON ANDREAS: Well, thanks,
you guys, for coming in.
We appreciate it.
It's awesome to have you jump
across town here and join us.
Super excited to have
you guys in town.
Excuse me.
Not just in Detroit,
but in town as well.
You guys have been getting
a lot of fantastic press
around Detroit.
And we'd love to hear a
little bit more about that.
Before we jump in and
talk about Prime + Proper,
we want to talk
about the sourcing
of the meat you guys have.
We've got Walter here to
talk about that, which
I think is going to be awesome.
We had a phone call a
couple of months ago.
And I can tell you would
love to talk about it.
Because he's a
very talkative guy.
And he dug it.
I grew up on a farm.
I don't know if you
remember me saying that?
WALTER APFELBAUM: Yeah, I
remember you saying that.
JASON ANDREAS: I
grew up on a farm.
So I was all ears.
So I'm excited to dig into
that a little bit more.
But before we do that,
we have chefs in.
We have restaurateurs in.
We'd love to kind
of get a, where
did you start, where did you
kind of catch the bug at,
and how did that turn into
where you guys are at now.
Just kind of lay the
foundation for all of us
so we understand where
you guys came from
and how you got to the
point that you guys are both
working together as
partners at Prime + Proper.
RYAN PRENTISS: Well, like
pretty much any great chef--
the vast majority of them--
I think both of
us started kind of
on the bottom, a little
bit different realms.
I started washing dishes when
I was 15-years old at Coney
Island in Baltimore,
Michigan-- so
a little bit of a
Northeaster here.
Worked there for
a couple of years.
Went and worked with my
uncle, who's also a chef--
my uncle Mike.
Worked for him for
probably six years or so.
He taught me a
whole lot of things.
I started off kind of washing
dishes at his restaurant,
and then kind of
worked my way up.
And by the time I
left working with him,
I was kind of managing
the kitchen with him.
I went to culinary school
right out of high school.
Never worked in
any other business
a single day in my
life, which is sometimes
kind of unnerving to me.
But it's like, it's what I do.
So I'm OK with it.
But yeah, I just worked through
several different, great
kitchens in this area.
I learned a lot from
a lot of good chefs
that have kind of since moved
on and went different ways.
I started working for Townhouse
Birmingham in 2014, I think.
And jumped on board with
that restaurant group.
And we've since opened Townhouse
Detroit and now Prime + Proper,
which I got to
meet this big guy.
So it's been a fun ride.
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome.
And what about you, Walter?
What's the origin story behind
how you came to Detroit?
WALTER APFELBAUM: Well, I'm
a born and raised Jersey boy,
right on the Jersey Shore.
And as you see, I don't
sound like those people
from the "Jersey Shore"
even though I grew up right
where they filmed all that.
I grew up in an
all-German household.
And it was, we don't
go to grocery stores.
You go to butcher shops.
And you go to the fishmonger.
You go to the bread guy
for bread and cheese--
it was like an all-day
excursion with my parents.
Just getting to eat
like that, and seeing
all of the passion
and love for people
that do what they do
best, and just growing up
with the butcher shop
right down the corner,
and spending all my time in
the shop from elementary school
up--
and literally it's the
only thing I've ever done,
is just I've always
been around beef.
And the guy that I was
learning from was like, here,
you're going to learn
everything from the bottom up.
And it was like,
here, you're going
to go help birth a
pig and birth cows.
And it was like,
ah, this is gross.
But it was important to
learn the entire process,
from birth to raising
them to harvesting them
to breaking them
down completely,
utilizing everything.
And then probably the most
important thing I learned
was how to talk to people
and trying to understand
what they were looking for.
A lot of people
nowadays, it's like, oh,
New York strips, and rib-eyes.
I'm like, the animal's huge.
There's so much more meat.
So trying to understand,
what are you making?
What are you going to be doing?
Maybe the rib-eye's not
the right pick for you.
Maybe the chuck end isn't.
And maybe an eye round
is right for you.
So it was all learning how to
make people comfortable with me
so that you trusted me.
You would come and see.
And it was important for me
to learn old-world butchery.
And that was old butchery, is
everybody trusted the butcher.
You trust your fish guy.
You trust your bread guy.
So trust was a big thing.
So he had taught me all this
and then started literally
pimping me out to all butcher
shops throughout New York,
all throughout the
city, Connecticut,
that whole tri-state area.
And then one day, finally
my buddy was like, hey,
I need help in a restaurant.
And I'm like, sure.
And I worked a day in a
restaurant in the butcher shop.
And I was like,
are you kidding me?
This is awesome.
And it was.
And then probably a
year or two after that,
then I moved right
into the restaurants
and haven't looked back.
I don't like to say I'm a
restaurant guy because I'm not.
I've not worked a day
in my life on the line.
I'm the guy that's going to
be a tool in his toolbox.
So that's what I've told all
the chefs, is, use me as a tool.
I'm here to make
your job easier,
make your job better,
to help the brand shine,
help the chef shine.
I'm not really one
for the spotlight.
I'd rather give the spotlight
to this guy or the brand
by providing the best.
RYAN PRENTISS: I've heard
you talk about your--
I like that you referred to
it as an origin story too.
It's kind of funny.
I've heard you talk about all
of your experiences before.
But you just managed to roll
birthing cattle and being
pimped out into
your origin story.
I love it.
JASON ANDREAS: See.
Once you get him
going, [INAUDIBLE]..
WALTER APFELBAUM: I'm
not even going yet.
I'm like, I got to
feel you guys out.
I got to see where you're at
before you get all of Walter.
It's a lot.
But I mean, pretty much,
that's where I was.
And it was important.
The guy was like, make sure
you go to culinary school.
So CIA in upstate New
York, I got a chance
to go work overseas
for several years--
which was awesome-- out
at Hamburg, Germany,
and just get to see
a lot of Africa,
a lot of the Middle East,
a lot of Eastern Europe,
northern Europe.
And it was great.
It was a lot of fun.
And I just butchered.
That's all I did.
It was a lot of butchery,
a lot of fishmongering.
I got to actually spend a lot
of time making cheese, which
was pretty cool.
I got to step away from
meat for about a year
and just make cheese,
which was really cool.
But it was still being
part of the dairy program
and getting the dairy
to make the cheese,
and getting to see the
dairy cows in Italy.
So it was awesome.
It was a lot of fun.
And now I'm here with this guy.
RYAN PRENTISS: Walter,
I want to pause
for a second on
a point you made.
So you went to the Culinary
Institute of America.
And you also mentioned
something before that,
that you're not really
a restaurant guy.
When you think of the CIA--
not the CIA, the Culinary
Institute of America--
you think more chefs,
folks are actually
going into the
restaurant business.
I think I read that you
were the only butcher
in your class at the CIA.
WALTER APFELBAUM:
That I knew of.
And it was horrible, man.
Mike, the guy that I learned
how to cook from, he was like,
oh, this is where you're going.
Little did I know
that when we got
into meat ID and
meat fabrication,
that they knew each other.
I had no idea.
So he's like, listen,
you're going to go.
And you're going to go blind.
You're just going to learn.
And I'm like, sure.
So I'm in the back
of the classroom
and he's just like,
oh, Walter will
come show us how to do this.
And I'm like, whoa, what?
I'm like, how do
you know I what?
So it was interesting.
So I spent a lot of my time just
being part of the meat class.
Even when we were
done with meat fab,
I was always there
helping teach kids.
But it was also great to learn
with young guys, like Ryan--
getting to see these kids,
and this is the future
that they're going.
And it's like, get to
see their minds work.
And it's like, OK, this
is where they want to go.
And what can I do to help that?
And it was awesome to get
to spend a lot of time
with some young chefs,
god, back in the 90s.
I've been refrigerated
all my life.
So I've kept my youthful look.
I'm going to be 44 in a month.
JASON ANDREAS:
That's the secret,
is spending time
in a refrigerator?
WALTER APFELBAUM: Yeah.
No sunlight, just refrigeration.
JASON ANDREAS: The Walter
Apfelbaum beauty regimen
right here.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Exactly.
JASON ANDREAS: Trademark
that before it gets out.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Just
spend time with me.
RYAN PRENTISS: Lamb fat.
Lamb fat all over yourself.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Oh, man.
Lamb fat is the key to life.
I tell everybody that.
You literally look
at the ingredients
for hand moisturizers,
skin lotions.
And the number one ingredient
is lanolin and lamb fat.
Most of it is lanolin.
So when everybody's
like, they shake my hand,
they're like, oh, my god,
Walter, your hands are so soft.
And they're like,
what do you use?
And I'm like, lanolin.
And it's awesome.
And it's good.
I mean, I put on my
lips a little bit.
It makes them soft.
My wife hates it.
She'll come and give me a kiss.
And she's like, oh,
my god, what is that?
She's like, stop, it's gross.
And I'm like, it's lamb fat.
Don't worry about it.
It's healthy.
JASON ANDREAS: It's natural.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS:
What took you then
from, again, the Jersey Shore,
the CIA, all over Europe,
Africa, Middle East, et cetera?
I know you were in
Florida most recently.
What brought you to Detroit?
And then what was the
story of how both of you
connected to kind of come
together at Prime + Proper?
WALTER APFELBAUM: I
actually got hired--
the Seminole Tribe of Florida
I was working for in Florida
before I started work with them.
They were in a partnership
with the Steinbrenners
that owned the Yankees.
And all the Yankees do all their
training in Tampa, Florida.
So they all lived in Tampa.
So they were working on their
steakhouse in Tampa, Council
Oak.
And they were also working
with the Steinbrenners
to be building NYY
Steak in Yankee Stadium.
And they were like,
listen, we got these guys
that don't know what they're
doing in the butcher shop
at Council Oak in Tampa.
We need to find somebody.
And it was the coolest
thing, that all of a sudden
here come the Seminole
Tribe leaders knocking
on my door going,
hey, come to Florida.
And I'm like, it's too hot.
But I wound up in
Florida for nine years
doing all their Council
Oak's in Tampa, Hollywood,
and then NYY Steak in Coconut
Creek Midtown Manhattan, Yankee
Stadium.
So I did all theirs.
And the next thing I know,
our owner Jeremy Sassoon
reached out via Instagram.
And I'm just like, I don't
know who this guy is.
I get all these messages.
Some weird creepo
guy is messaging me.
And I'm like, I don't know.
What is this guy doing?
So I finally answered him.
And then we talked.
And he's just like,
yeah, you should come up.
And I'm like, well,
where are you at?
This is such a great idea.
I love your concept,
everything about it.
And he's like, I'm in Detroit.
And I'm like, no.
Outside of Detroit, they
don't talk about this.
And I'm like, man, I don't know.
It's Detroit.
There's no way I'm going
to convince my wife
to move to Detroit.
My father is going to murder me.
You're not going to
see me ever again.
And then he's like,
no, let's fly up.
So he flew me up here.
And literally, he brought
me right downtown.
And I was like, flashbacks
of 1980s New York.
And I'm like, this is amazing.
I was like, this is New
York all over again for me,
being a child and watching New
York grow to what it is now,
like Brooklyn.
Good luck buying anything in
Brooklyn, Manhattan, downtown.
It's amazing.
The street life, the whole
vibe of New York is incredible.
And I remember when it wasn't.
I remember when
it was just like,
hurry up, get in, get out.
And it was not the
best place to be.
And I remember watching
just New York come up
to where it is now.
So when I got here, I
was like, holy mackerel,
this is New York.
This is New York in the 80s.
And I was like, this is amazing.
I couldn't believe
the construction
and the people, the whole vibe.
And then I told him that night,
I'm like, I'm totally down.
Where do I sign?
I'm down.
Literally, my words
to Jeremy was,
you're building Peter Lugars.
I was like, that's
what you're doing.
You're building an
institution that you
can't put a price tag on.
I would love to be the guy that
goes, I opened Peter Lugars.
I opened Keynes.
I opened Delmonico's.
I can't.
But Prime + Proper?
Yeah.
In Detroit?
This is amazing.
It's great to be part of
Detroit's up and coming,
and being where it needs to be.
Putting it right back on
that pedestal of just being
an amazing city to be part of.
JASON ANDREAS: And
Jeremy on that first trip
took you to Eastern
Market, as I understand.
So that's the tie-in to--
you mentioned the early
days in the Jersey Shore
going to the fishmonger, and the
butcher, and things like that.
So a nice tie-in to
bring that full circle.
WALTER APFELBAUM:
Bring the pizza, man.
He brought me to Supino's.
That was the first thing we had.
We had Supino's.
He's like, you're from Jersey.
And I'm like, yeah.
And we went into Supino's.
And I was like, holy crap.
I'm like, OK, this
is Detroit pizza?
Yep.
I'm down.
Get some good pizza, get
some good beers, I'm down.
JASON ANDREAS: Absolutely.
So with Prime +
Proper, you guys have
stated that kind of
part of your mission
is to bring back the
classic American steakhouse,
but to update it
with modern features.
Can you talk a little bit about
how you guys came together,
where that concept
came from, and really
what that actually means?
What can folks expect if they
haven't been to Prime + Proper
yet?
RYAN PRENTISS: Like
Walter can kind of
speak about, like
Keynes, Peter Lugars--
these are meccas of
kind of steakhouses.
And there's not a lot of places
like that that still exist
or that are continuing
to kind of open.
Jeremy and I had met a
bunch of times with Walter.
We had the concept in line.
And we kind of convinced
him to come on board.
And as we got the ball
rolling for the whole concept,
it just became more
and more extravagant.
Like Walter said, trying to
become kind of an institution.
There's a lot of
places that open up.
A lot of great restaurants
downtown that maybe open.
And their concept is a little
more trendy, a little more
kind of of-the-minute.
We kind of went the
other direction.
Let's take creamed spinach
or something like that,
or let's take a
classic steakhouse dish
and make it up to
date, and make it
on par with those
kind of restaurants,
and really put our thought into
it as chefs and as butchers,
and bring it into 2018
and so on from there.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: And you
guys mentioned you're not
in the restaurant business.
You're in the
experience business.
So you take this concept of
a more classic steakhouse.
What's the experience you guys
are going for then within kind
of the bookend of
a Peter Lugars,
or a Keynes, or
something like that.
RYAN PRENTISS: So kind of like
Walt was saying about tailoring
the experience to each person,
you go to talk to the butcher
and you say that you like
a certain type of steak,
but maybe as the
butcher talks to you
and finds out different
things about what you actually
enjoy to eat, he might point
you in a different direction.
When we say we're in
the experience business,
we're not in it to make just
great food, or great drinks,
or have great service.
It's all those sort
of and then some--
trying to bring it all together.
And you don't necessarily
think of, well,
I had a great meal
at Prime + Proper.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Great memory.
RYAN PRENTISS: Yeah,
I had a great memory.
WALTER APFELBAUM: It's something
that we want you to remember.
It's not like going into
a place and going, yeah,
I'm going to have the fillet.
It's like, oh, OK.
Well, a fillet.
Really?
It's like, well,
come talk to me.
And it's about trying
to educate people
without letting them know
that you're educating them.
You don't want to make
people feel uncomfortable.
I'm trying to educate you.
But I'm also trying
to figure you out.
I'm trying to read you
to see where you're at.
Because so many people
are like, fillet.
I'm comfortable.
And it's like, OK,
great, a fillet.
But let me see what else.
Talk to me.
How do you like
your steaks cooked?
What flavors are
you looking for?
What textures are
Because I'm not just
about to sell you a steak.
I want to make sure I'm
selling you that experience,
I'm selling you a memory.
And I want to make sure
that it's everything.
It's just not my steak.
It's going to be
what Ryan's making.
It's what's going along with it.
You're talking about
a fillet, something
that's dime a dozen compared
to what's in my case.
And you look in my case.
And you're looking at USDA prime
beef that's dry-aged in-house.
It's 1 and 1/2 percent of
the beef in the nation.
So do you really
want dime a dozen
or do you want 1 and 1/2 percent
of the beef in the nation?
So it's an experience.
And I get people
that want fillets.
And if that's what you want,
then that's what you want.
It's hopefully next
time you come in
that you take my advice.
And it's like, have
that New York strip.
And the next time
you come in, have
the bone in your New York strip,
and just work your way up.
I don't expect someone to go
from well-done to rare in one
sitting.
I want baby steps.
I want to create
a family with you.
I want you to be
part of my family.
And I want you to understand.
I want you to believe in me.
I want you to believe in the
chef, believe in our staff.
We're going to make sure
that we're giving you
the best of the best.
JASON ANDREAS: You led
me perfectly, Walter.
Because I have a question
about some of the values
that your restaurant runs on.
And I think it's
really interesting,
because we're sitting in
a company like Google.
We have some friends
here from Olympia.
Again, this concept of,
you are a restaurant,
but you're more about
experiences and memories,
and also you talk a lot about
customer experiences as well.
So on your website, you've
got five prime values.
And I'm going to read them
out just so everyone has them.
So consistently care about
the smallest details,
love all people with enlightened
hospitality, own it with pride,
willingness to learn
and teach, and believe
in everything you say and do.
I think this is
really interesting.
I've never seen on a
restaurant's web site
the values that they
kind of command by.
Where did these come from?
And how do you guys apply
those to kind of this concept
that you've already
talked about?
WALTER APFELBAUM:
Well, we live it.
When Jeremy sat down--
we all sat in a room
with the core people
that we opened up with.
Jeremy pretty much took
our personal beliefs
and just was like, here, boom.
This is what you believe in.
This is what I believe in.
And we're going
to make it happen.
When you bring people like
Ryan, and myself, and Liz,
and Sharon, our pastry chef--
these are all people that
exude enlightened hospitality.
I want to teach you.
I want to learn from you.
I'm always like,
what's going on?
What can I learn?
It's amazing what I can
learn and what I can teach.
I'll sit there.
And I'll just hover
over Ryan where
I'll piss him off
because I'll just
be like, hey, we need to get
this, hey, we need to get this.
And I'll bother him for a month.
Be like, hey, we
need to get this.
And then he does.
And he's just like, oh, yeah.
And I'm like, yeah, you see.
And then he'll do
the same thing to me.
And I'm like, oh,
yeah, look at that.
I never even knew that.
It's something that
we wake up with, man.
We go to sleep with,
we wake up with.
And it's who we are as people.
RYAN PRENTISS: That's how we've
built the team that we have.
We don't necessarily hire
just solely on experience.
I mean, yeah, it plays
a big part of it.
But the vast majority
of why we hire people
is if they fit those values.
10 times out of
10, I'd rather take
somebody that may not
have as much experience,
but that really has
that drive to learn
and just wants to come
into the restaurant.
And we've got people that
work in our kitchen that
have been executive chefs, that
have been sous chefs, chef de
cuisines.
And then we have people that
have worked their way up
from dishwasher position.
And they're this great mix.
And the reason that they
all work so well together,
and that we're able to
leave the restaurant
and come and do something like
this, and someone's experience
is going to be just
as great tonight
if we were in the building,
because these people all
collaborate together.
And they're all willing
to learn from each other.
| the executive chef
might learn something
from somebody that was a steward
at somewhere else-- that maybe
he's been doing something
one way for 10 years.
And all of a sudden,
he turns around.
And the steward is doing
something that completely
flipped the script
on what he thought
had to be done a certain way.
JASON ANDREAS: Sure.
I love that concept
in terms of what
you mentioned
around hiring around
fit and culture versus kind
of the old-school methodology,
which has existed
and still exists
a lot more of the
restaurant world.
In the business
world, when we talk
about a company like Google,
we switched a long time ago,
where instead of looking
at where somebody graduated
or what their experience was,
we were looking more about
whether they were a fit, right?
And you have folks who come in
from all different backgrounds,
and study different things in
undergrad and graduate school
that have nothing to do
what we do at Google.
But they're the
right type of person.
And that makes a huge difference
versus just looking at a resume
and saying, they've got 20
years experience, but they might
be a jerk, or they might
be conceited, or cocky,
or whatever it might be.
WALTER APFELBAUM: When you're
open, and you want to learn,
and you want to help teach,
and change doesn't scare you,
I mean, that's what it's about.
I mean, if change scared me, I
would have never left Jersey.
I wouldn't be here.
I love change.
I'm about to be 44-years old.
And I'm just like,
give me something new.
Let's go.
I can learn something?
Sure.
Let's go.
I want to do it.
I literally talked to Jeremy
the other day about going back
to school for meat science.
He was just like,
are you serious?
I'm like, yeah, let's go.
I'm down.
AUDIENCE: Can I
audit that class?
WALTER APFELBAUM: What?
AUDIENCE: Can I
audit that class?
[CHUCKLING]
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah, right.
WALTER APFELBAUM: It's awesome.
JASON ANDREAS: In
this kind of ecosystem
that we've been talking about
for the past 20 minutes or so,
what's the relationship then
between an executive chef
and a butcher?
How do you guys work together?
And let me also throw a side
question in specifically
for Walter.
So in 2017, Ryan was named
one of "People" magazine's
sexiest chef.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN PRENTISS: You're
going to bring this up?
This is the worst PR ever.
JASON ANDREAS: I sent him a
list of questions yesterday.
And I left that one off.
WALTER APFELBAUM: He told me
not to say anything about that.
And I was like, hmm,
where can I work this in?
JASON ANDREAS: So I'm
going to sneak that in.
RYAN PRENTISS: I had people
harassing me in the dining--
because our kitchen
is very open.
There's a meat display case.
JASON ANDREAS:
Whistling, cat-calling.
RYAN PRENTISS: Oh, yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: I
want to know, did you
notice a difference in him after
that article came out as well?
The dynamic between you
two, and then did it change?
WALTER APFELBAUM: He
stands a lot taller.
He stands a lot taller.
He's like, you see me?
You know who I am, right?
[LAUGHS]
RYAN PRENTISS: You
screwed me all up.
You're asking me questions.
And I was just like--
WALTER APFELBAUM: Yeah,
we're totally off track now.
RYAN PRENTISS: --all right,
yeah, no, I got this one.
We got a great answer now.
JASON ANDREAS: So the dynamic
between a butcher and a chef,
kind of the concept of Prime
+ Proper, and also the culture
that you guys talked
about as well?
Sorry to throw things off there.
I had to throw that in there.
RYAN PRENTISS: I'm
going home now.
I'm done.
[CHUCKLING]
No.
It's the same as any other of
the aspects of our kitchen.
I'm very much not the person--
I've worked for chefs that,
this is how I want it done.
This is my kitchen.
This is my so and so.
This is my dish or whatever.
None of that applies
where we are.
It's a collaborative
effort between chefs
to make a great
experience for our guests.
Walter and I just happen to have
experiences that align fairly
well.
And it's a constant
kind of back and forth.
We are gearing up to actually
start running this week,
starting Wednesday,
this really cool--
imagine a porterhouse
or a T bone steak.
So it's got the
filet on one side.
But then instead of
having the New York
strip on the other
side, we actually
have a 1-pound lobster tail
that we butter poach, and then
slice, and then laid it out.
So it looks like the section
of the New York strip.
This is one of those
things that Walter's
kind of been like bugging
me about, and bugging me
about, and bugging me about.
And finally, he just
called our fish guy
and was like, give me one
of these lobster tails.
And he put it up.
And we're like,
all right, great.
And then one of our
sous chefs looked at it.
He's been working on this
really cool caviar beurre blanc.
And he said, hey, why
don't we put this--
because this caviar beurre
blanc has a little bit
of lobster in the base.
Let's put some here.
Everybody just kind
of builds on top.
Walter and myself-- yeah, we're
the final call on everything.
But everybody in the
restaurant kind of has a voice.
Whether it's our prep
team, service staff,
back-of-house
management, we all kind
of just bounce ideas off
of each other constantly.
And a lot of them start
with jokes, oddly enough.
I like to think about
food as, it's all good.
There's no like, oh, well,
this isn't the right fit
at Prime + Proper, we can't use
that here, that's out the door.
I didn't grew up eating the
type of food that we serve.
So I have this weird
background of just eating
normal, blue-collar
kind of stuff.
So I always try and sneak
those kind of things in.
Perfect example--
our Mac and cheese
is made with evaporated milk
and velveeta as the base.
And then we fold all these
other great ingredients into it,
and use a really
great pasta, and then
level it up kind of that way.
But like I said, a lot of
things will start off as a joke.
But then all of a sudden, Walker
shows up with a 1-pound lobster
tail and we're pouring caviar
beurre blanc on top of it.
WALTER APFELBAUM:
And it looks so good.
RYAN PRENTISS: It does.
It looks really cool.
Yeah.
WALTER APFELBAUM: If you
go on to our social media,
you'll see the picture of it.
Oh, man, it's awesome.
And it's so good too.
JASON ANDREAS: That's awesome.
Walter, can you
talk a little bit
about going back to kind
of the meat side of things.
Talk about the process
of sourcing, right?
You talked about where
some of your inspiration
comes from growing up around
butchers, and cheese mongers,
and things like that.
What is your process
here now in Detroit?
You take a lot of pride in the
type of meat that you bring in.
From start to finish, what
does that look like for you,
from sourcing to bringing in?
WALTER APFELBAUM: Sourcing
is so important, especially
when you're talking about
fine dining and what I do.
And it's all about
relationships.
And I've had the
same relationship
with the gentleman I
buy beef from now--
we've known each
other 20-plus years.
And I've been buying from
him probably the same amount
of time.
And he's one of the largest beef
buyers there is in the nation.
So when you have that much
pull in the beef business,
you get first pick
of everything.
And it's so important that I'm
getting the same quality 52
weeks of the year.
It's so important.
Consistency for me is key.
It's key for what
we're building here.
You want consistency.
You want something that's going
to last 30 years, 40 years, 50
years--
something that's
not going to change.
You may only come eat
with us once a year.
But that once a year, that
steak is going to be the same.
And meat is also seasonal.
Right now is the best time to
buy beef because it's marbled.
So summertime is
the hardest time
for my guy to buy beef for me.
Him and his guy source all
throughout the Midwest.
And they're dealing
with the best
ranchers you're going to find.
These guys are meat scientists.
And you go out and you see them.
And they look like cowboys.
But these guys know
more about everything.
They know about the
genetics of the animal.
They want to make sure
that those genetics are
the right genetics.
My guy also knows that
I'm not buying angus.
So it's a little
bit more difficult
when I'm not buying angus.
He's looking for [INAUDIBLE].
He's looking for guys that
care more about those animals
than anything.
So regardless if he's buying
it from Idaho, or Colorado,
or where he's
buying it from, he's
buying it from the right people.
He's buying it from those
guys that are going,
listen, I know my
genetics, I know my feed,
I know the pastures that these
animals are being raised in,
I know everything about them.
And that's so important
to me because I
need to make sure that
when you come to eat,
you're going to be
getting the best.
Granted, it may not be
coming from Michigan.
But maybe none of
the guys around here
are going to be able to
supply me with what I need.
what the public needs.
Because it's not really
so much about me or Ryan.
It's about the brand.
And we need to make sure
that that brand gets
the best possible
product that you're going
to find anywhere in the nation.
And I'd rather be the guy that
gets that than someone else.
I'd rather have you guys
here in Detroit be like, man,
we're getting the best
beef in the nation.
It's all grass-fed,
pasture-raised.
And there's a huge misconception
when people are like, oh,
but it's corn fed
or corn-finished.
And I'm like, yeah,
it's corn-finished.
But it's not what
you think it is.
A lot of people have
this misconception
that these guys are just
walking with big bags of corn,
and dumping them in the
troughs, and these animals
are eating big bags of corn.
It's not.
If you actually look at the
feed from every single feedlot,
there's more grass
in there than corn.
As a matter of fact,
on my Instagram page--
or was that a year--
RYAN PRENTISS: It was
well over a year ago.
Yeah.
WALTER APFELBAUM:
About a year and a half
ago maybe, we went to the
Tiffany Cattle Company
in Kansas.
And it was great
because I was there
to actually take pictures
and see their feed operation.
And you actually look at the
feed that these animals are on.
And it's mostly grasses.
It's going to be
grasses, barley.
There's going to be grains.
There's going to be
some corn in there.
But there's mainly grasses.
So everybody is like,
oh, corn-fed is bad.
No, it's not.
Corn-fed is great.
There is nothing wrong
with corn-fed beef.
I get people telling me all
the time-- they're like,
oh, I only eat grass-fed beef.
And I'm like, well, that's
great because all beef
in the entire
world is grass-fed.
It's like, what is
it finished then?
People are like, I don't know,
what are you talking about.
And it's like, if you've
ever had grass-finished beef,
it's very earthy.
It's something else.
So most of the time when
people are eating beef,
it's going to be
grain-finished beef.
And grain-finished
beef is where you're
going to get that
sweet, beautiful flavor.
You're going to get that
beautiful intramuscular fat.
And the textures, the
flavors is everything.
And once again, this is going
to be ranchers that actually
care about these animals.
The more you care
about these animals,
the more it's going to be
worth to them in the end.
So they don't want sick animals.
They want super healthy animals.
They want them to eat
the best food possible.
Because the more yield
that they can get off
of these animals, the more
money they're worth to them.
So hopefully that--
JASON ANDREAS: Walter's
got 66,000 Instagram
followers in case anyone's
interested in joining in.
I suggest the follow.
You talk about
consistency, right,
with the type of
beef that you source.
Could you talk a
little bit more--
and you delved into
it just a little bit--
this concept of
sustainability as well?
Because that's an important
topic when it comes to any food
sourcing, but meat in
particular right now.
What are your thoughts
on kind of sustainability
and how that plays into what
you're looking at as well?
WALTER APFELBAUM: It's
a little bit tough
because everybody's like oh,
well, you should buy local.
And I agree.
I love the concept of local.
But to be brutally
honest, you're
not going to find what we
need in just one or two farms.
It's difficult to
answer this question.
Because it has to come
from all over the Midwest.
It's not coming from one farm.
It's not coming from two farms.
It's coming from multiple farms.
Because maybe this
rancher only has 200 head.
But guess what?
Out of that 200 head,
only one of them
is going to be up
to my standards.
So it's going to be--
man, that's tough.
RYAN PRENTISS: I think more
along the lines of the way
that we source beef
is we find the best
of the best of the best.
And I think that as farms
transition, like Walter
was saying, they
want these cattle
to be as healthy as possible.
They're not feeding them
a bunch of antibiotics
and all this crazy stuff just
because, oh, we'll raise it
and then slaughter it.
They want them to be healthy.
They want them to grow at a
healthy rate for that animal.
And it's sustainable to--
as these farms become
more sustainable
and as the meat industry kind of
transitions in that direction,
the level of quality
may change a bit.
Like he's saying, out of a farm
that has 200 head of cattle,
only one of them might
be up to our standards.
So the level of quality
may drop a little bit
as things become
more sustainable,
but that's just the
nature of the beast.
JASON ANDREAS: Walter,
you talked a little bit
about grass-fed versus corn-fed,
some of the misperceptions
there.
What are some other
misperceptions
or common misperceptions
that you hear about the meat
industry as well today?
WALTER APFELBAUM: Oh, man.
I hear people like, oh, you
buy from a large packing house.
It's like, oh, well, I only
buy from this small guy,
that they take the animal back
and you don't see what happens.
And it's like, OK, that's great.
In the meantime, you look at
IBP, one of the largest packing
houses there is.
They care so much.
What's her name?
Temple-- oh, shit.
Temple something.
Can never remember her name.
She's huge into the way
animals are harvested.
And if you look at these
huge packing plants like IBP,
these animals are brought
into the finishing pens.
And they're only
filled about 70% full.
They have these misters
on so there's cold water
so it keeps the animal
super calm and relaxed.
There's no stun guns.
There's no tasers.
These guys walk around
with Hefty black garbage
bags full of air on long rods.
And they just move them just
to get the animals moving.
So when it's time for
them to be knocked--
and knocking is when the
piston is driven into the brain
to sever everything--
they're actually brought
into single file.
And the walls are really high.
And so they don't see people.
And they're brought
in individually.
They can't see what's
going on in front of them.
And it's a whole comfort thing.
They have no idea
what's going on.
And then before you
know it, it's over.
And you want
something like that.
You want that because the less
stress there is on the animal,
the better the
meat's going to be.
When you're talking about a
lot of these small-time guys--
and I know a lot
of the guys too.
They'll get up there on
their tractor with their 22.
And they're just trying
to wrangle up this animal.
And he's just stressed
out because they
don't know what's going on.
And then the next thing you
know, there's just a boom
and then the animal is down.
And it's like, well,
you just stressed out
this entire animal.
Compared to IBP and those guys
where there's vets on premises.
They're looking at
every single animal.
The USDA guys are constantly
inspecting every single animal.
They're trying to
utilize everything
they need to make
sure these animals are
healthiest that they can be,
the cleanest they can be.
You bruise an animal when
you harvest the animal,
there's a huge section of loss.
And that's loss.
And I hate to say it, but
when it comes down to it,
it's about money.
They want to make as
much money as possible.
So the cleaner the animals
are, the healthier the animals
are, the cleaner the
animals are harvested,
you're going to have a
much usable product, which
is going to be gain for them.
So there's a lot of people
like, oh, you buy from IBP?
And it's like, yeah,
look at the meat.
They trust in their company.
They trust in their workers.
They trust in their vets.
They hire vets that they
don't even need to hire.
You take a look at small-time
guys, a lot of them
can't afford to unfortunately.
Now, don't get me wrong.
I've had plenty of
small-time farms
that produced great stuff.
But the masses that
I need and the masses
that a lot of other
restaurants need,
you won't be able to supply us.
JASON ANDREAS:
Again, I mentioned
I grew up on a dairy farm.
Talking about animal
comfort, I often
joke that they live a
pretty darn good life there.
They sleep on these
nice air mattresses.
They have misters year round.
They've got heating units--
WALTER APFELBAUM: You've got
to keep them comfortable.
JASON ANDREAS:
--heated mattresses.
They listen to music.
These cows seem pretty
chill every time I see them.
And they're pretty
delicious too.
WALTER APFELBAUM: That's
a whole other thing
too with being grown
up on a dairy farm.
A lot of people are
like-- they'll say,
oh, how do you feel about veal?
And I'm like, I love veal.
And they're like, how
could you eat a baby?
And I'm like, OK, here we go.
I'm like, it's on.
I'm like, you need to
understand dairy farmers
need to keep their
cows pregnant,
keep producing milk, not meat.
Milk.
If they birth a male,
you're not going
to be able to milk a male.
What else are you
going to do with it?
It's not like it's
a horrible thing.
They just don't have a place
to put a male dairy cow.
I don't know.
What were you guys raising?
Jerseys?
JASON ANDREAS: Holstein.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Holstein.
And there's not really a
big call for Holstein meat.
So it goes to a great place.
It's just a touchy subject.
A lot of people don't
like to talk about it.
But veal is amazing.
I'm also from Jersey.
So you grow up on veal.
But yeah.
I mean, I'm sure
you probably heard
a lot about it growing up.
It's like, ooh, we don't
want to talk about this.
JASON ANDREAS:
Well, we talk a lot
about sustainability
in the milk industry
as well, because there's
a lot of alternatives that
can be good or some that lack
a lot of the health aspects
of actual real animal milk.
And so you talk
about sustainability
when it comes to that as well.
And the other part
of that is as folks
look towards other
alternatives to dairy
milk, a lot of
small-to-medium dairy farmers
are going out of business.
They're used to being--
WALTER APFELBAUM:
Which is a shame.
JASON ANDREAS:
--hundreds of thousands
of dairy farmers around America.
Now they're in the thousands.
And when they all
go out of business--
if that's what it comes
to with low milk prices--
then what happens?
And there's some of the same
concerns within the meat
industry as well, I know.
So this idea of
sustainability I think
is really interesting,
essentially
as it pertains to where
your knowledge lies.
WALTER APFELBAUM:
It definitely vary.
I mean, also, going back to
feed, all cattle is grass-fed.
All of it.
And right now in
Kansas, they're having
an issue with lack of rain.
So they're not actually
being able to graze off
the grass because there aren't
any because of the weather.
This isn't the first time.
This isn't the last time.
It's happened over and over.
They depend on a lot of guys.
I believe most of
them are in Idaho.
And they grow alfalfa.
And they grow barley.
They grow a bunch of stuff.
And they actually
make pellets that
are actually sold to all
these farmers, like in Kansas
right now.
So you look a lot of
the cattle, they're
eating all these
great natural pellets.
And a lot of that is actually
going to wind up healthier
than just grazing
off of grasses,
which is really, really nice.
JASON ANDREAS: Let's pull
things back to Detroit.
We're obviously huge
fans of the city.
Google just recently
moved downtown.
And we're very excited
to be down here.
You guys are a staple now of the
downtown dining and experience
industry.
What do you guys see
over the next one or two
years for downtown
Detroit and how
you guys will fit into that?
RYAN PRENTISS: Man.
One of the things-- and I know
it's kind of a thing in every
industry, but sort of
the skilled labor--
not necessarily having
people that are really here
that are dedicated
to this industry.
We're lucky because
we're staffed with people
that this is what they do.
Nobody that works
at Prime + Proper
is just there because
they get a paycheck.
They're there because
they're either a great server
or they're somebody that
wants to work in the kitchen
and really learn
everything they can.
There's restaurants opening
every 20 minutes pretty
much downtown.
It's crazy.
WALTER APFELBAUM:
Yeah, that's crazy.
RYAN PRENTISS: I mean, it's
kind of interesting for me,
having been in this
market my entire life
and my entire career,
seeing how it's changed now.
You have chefs
coming from Chicago.
You have butchers
coming from Florida.
We have--
WALTER APFELBAUM:
Not from Florida.
[CHUCKLING]
JASON ANDREAS: Coming
from Jersey via Florida.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Via Florida.
RYAN PRENTISS: Via Jersey via
Florida via New York City.
JASON ANDREAS: Sorry to
our Florida watchers.
It's a beautiful state.
WALTER APFELBAUM: My
wife's from Florida.
Too hot.
RYAN PRENTISS: We have
all these people kind
of coming into the city.
And just seeing the way that
not just the downtown area
is changing, but the culinary
scene in the city is.
We've had a lot of good
people here for a long time.
And now it's expanding.
And the demand is
growing every day.
And one of the cool
things that I'm
seeing a rise in
that is supporting
all of the restaurants
that are opening
is there's a lot
of great purveyors
that are sort of popping
up from seemingly nowhere.
That's kind of been
one of my gripes
with this market for
my whole careers,
is getting the level of
beef that Walter brings,
or getting the level of seafood,
or getting all these things
that you can get
in larger markets--
New York, Chicago.
And finally having people
that are like, hey,
there's all these
restaurants in Detroit,
I'm going to open up
my own seafood company.
I'm going to start delivering
truffles door to door.
And you can pick and choose
the ones that you want.
WALTER APFELBAUM: It's awesome
to see them coming, by the way.
RYAN PRENTISS: Yeah.
WALTER APFELBAUM: It's crazy.
They come with a little
cooler full of truffles.
I'm like, ooh.
JASON ANDREAS: Last year, we had
RecoveryPark Farms in as well.
So you've got sourcing of--
you've got some urban
farms and things
like that in the area that
have been around for a while,
but that are also
sourcing very locally
as well in terms of
vegetables, and produce,
and things like that.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Oh, yeah.
I mean, we deal with
a good friend of mine,
who I actually met
via Instagram, Eric--
I wish I knew how to
say his last name.
RYAN PRENTISS:
[INAUDIBLE] or something.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Yeah.
He's a good dude.
He's actually from here,
moved to California.
He was in California
for God knows how long.
He worked really close
with Thomas Keller,
developed poultry for Thomas
Keller in the French Laundry.
And I didn't know
that he was from here.
And then he sent me a message.
And he's like, holy shit,
Walter, you're in Detroit?
I'm moving back to Detroit.
And I'm like, what
do you mean "back?"
And then he's like,
I'm from the area.
And the next thing we know,
he's back in the area.
And he's raising--
like I told Ryan.
I'm like, listen,
this guy's here.
And we need to talk to him.
And he came in, and
just brought us rabbits
and brought us chickens.
And now he's raising hogs.
RYAN PRENTISS: Berkshire hogs.
WALTER APFELBAUM:
Yeah, Berkshire hogs.
And he's one of
those ranchers that I
talked about earlier
that really dives
super deep into everything.
He's just not getting
them to raise them.
He's making sure that
we're he's raising
them is going to be right.
It's all about where
they're going to live,
and what they're
going to forage,
what they're going to eat, what
they're going to drink, what's
the weather like.
And Eric really goes deep.
So it was great that we've dealt
with him for-- we did a rabbit
dinner with him.
We did our Thanksgiving
chickens with him.
RYAN PRENTISS: Yeah.
When we did the James
Beard dinner last August,
he gave us these really,
really nice [INAUDIBLE]..
There was little tiny chickens.
And we made these really
nice galantines with them.
And the flavor on them was
just absolutely incredible.
But that's kind of like--
WALTER APFELBAUM: Dealing
with the right people.
RYAN PRENTISS: Yeah.
The different farms,
and different purveyors,
and sort of sourcing locally.
That local,
sustainable in the same
conversation as the consistency
is always a tough one,
especially for us.
JASON ANDREAS: It's
a balance, right?
RYAN PRENTISS: Yeah.
We're talking about
a steakhouse that we
want to become an institution.
While we have sustainability
and sourcing locally
in mind as much as possible,
like he was saying, if somebody
comes in once a year, we've
got to make sure that that's
hitting the nail on the head.
WALTER APFELBAUM: And it's
not about a year or two years.
I'm looking farther--
30 years, 40 years, 50 years.
We should be that institution
that 100 years from now,
when they talk about great
steakhouses, it's like, man,
we've been talking about
this steakhouse for 90 years.
And it's like, this is
someplace you need to go--
just like Peter Lugars,
Keynes, the big boys.
And it's right where we're at.
I mean, we're in an amazing
city that's exploding,
which is awesome.
I couldn't ask to
be in a better city.
And I've worked
all over the world.
And this is just awesome.
It's amazing to be part of it.
And I want to make sure that
what standards Ryan and I set
now are going to be
the same standards
there are going to be
40 years down the road,
regardless if you're
buying it local here
or if you have to source
outside of the Michigan area.
While it's not right here
now, it may be right later.
JASON ANDREAS: And we're happy
to have you guys in Detroit.
There's been
steakhouses in Detroit.
But you guys have certainly
taken it to another level,
right?
And it's so interesting
hearing you guys talk.
You talk about consistency,
sustainability, culture,
all of these different things.
You're not a restaurant
that's looking
to be around for one or
two years and ride a trend.
You guys are here for
a long time, which
I think is really interesting.
And that's what we like
to see in Detroit as well,
is folks who kind of
plant their feet, kind of
come up with something
interesting and something
a little bit different.
And again, the experiential part
is really interesting as well.
So we're very stoked to
have you guys around.
I'll leave on one question.
I read that the
Golden State Warriors
swung through and shut
down the restaurant
about a week and a half ago.
RYAN PRENTISS: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: If you want to
become an institution, that's
a good way to do it, is have
visiting professional sports
teams shut the restaurant down.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Oh, yeah, man.
JASON ANDREAS: They
lost first of all.
The Pistons were able
to pick them off.
But what was that process
like for you guys?
Any good stories you
can share with us?
WALTER APFELBAUM: I know
the next day I came in--
I looked at my
Japanese Miyazaki.
I left, and it was this big.
And I come back,
and it's this big.
And I'm like, what happened?
And they're like, well, one of
the guys wanted a whole steak.
And I'm like, what?
I'm like, first of
all, it's gross.
I'm like, that's just so rich.
There's a lot.
There's a reason why we cut
them into 3 and 6 ounces.
And they're like, no,
he wanted a whole steak.
And I'm like, are you serious,
you just cut a 21-ounce steak
of Japanese Miyazaki wagyu?
I'm like, oh, all right, man.
If that's what they
want to do, then that's
what they want to do.
JASON ANDREAS: They
can afford it, right?
WALTER APFELBAUM: Yeah.
I mean, that was what I
walked into the next day.
And I just was
like, that's a lot.
I'm good for an
ounce to 2 ounces.
And I'm down.
RYAN PRENTISS: As much as we
talk about being consistent
and being this great
place, it's also
we kind of wanted to
be one of those places
where people could just come,
and just ball out, and just
go crazy, and put
crab oscar on top
of whatever, white truffles,
and just go crazy with it.
I mean, the last couple
of times Walter's had
some friends of his in, we've
made these insane meat platters
with burgers, and
dry-aged fillets, and bits
of rib-eye, and bone marrow,
like braised short ribs
in them.
And here comes this big, giant
copper platter just covered
in meat.
WALTER APFELBAUM:
Meat sweat heaven.
RYAN PRENTISS: Yeah.
JASON ANDREAS: If you
ever need a taste-tester,
just give me a shout.
Literally, I could be at your
restaurant in about 10 minutes.
WALTER APFELBAUM: You
bring bourbon, bro.
I got plenty of meat.
JASON ANDREAS: Yeah,
I'll come over.
Yeah.
RYAN PRENTISS: We have a lot
more than beef jerky there.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON ANDREAS: Thank
you guys for coming in.
Super interesting.
We wish you the best of luck.
Like I said, we're
excited to have you guys
in the city of Detroit.
We love what you guys are doing.
And it's awesome to kind of hear
some the story behind Prime +
Proper as well.
So thank you, guys.
Really appreciate it.
RYAN PRENTISS: Yeah.
WALTER APFELBAUM: Thank you.
RYAN PRENTISS:
Thanks for having me.
WALTER APFELBAUM: [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]